we have a few questions where were you  the night Lily bridges disappeared  Lucy this is Lilly Lilly Lucy fly so how  long have you been in Japan three weeks  now  - weird no everyone stares at you it's  like being famous  some people get addicted to those you  and not normal  either are you know  so let's not pretend to be you  photograph everything of course  do you have a boyfriend thank you he's  so cute cute Ohio he's gorgeous he's  like obsessed with you why do you say  that I know man she's a piece of work  that one it's like you the only one who  exists then she moves on to someone else  it's like you were never even there  what do you say about the future come on  we have something no one knows could  share  don't you ever I do I know what I'm  feeling  and it's not right at all  you must trust me  feels like something really Bad's gonna  happen  you